we're joined by reince priebus president
trump's former chief of staff and cbs
news contributor maria elena
salinas is joining us we're hoping
robbie mook who is hillary clinton's
former campaign manager he's supposed to
join us on this conversation but live tv
the signal went down just as we were
getting ready to go to him but listen
guys we will start our conversation if
they get it worked out robbie will join
us
maria elena i want to start with you
reince good to see you
because this was history making good to
see you
history making it was history shaking it
up last night
so i want to start marie elena with the
history making because here we have
kamala harris
who is the third woman nominated for
vice president the first woman of color
could you paint the picture on why this
is so significant other than the obvious
well just like you said she's not the
first woman to be a
vice presidential candidate but somehow
this feels different and i think
the moment that we're living in probably
contributes to that
i mean she can attract a whole coalition
of
voters women african-americans asians
immigrants as a whole children of
immigrants also
i mean she is very relatable because
people
will see her you know immigrant families
will see her and imagine their kids in
that position and
and kids of immigrants can say that
could be me you know and her speech last
night
i think was really important because she
showed all the different facets to her
it was very diverse she showed that she
could be a tough prosecutor ready to
take on
president trump but you could also
relate to her as a woman
as a stepmom as a woman in her 40s who
met her husband on a blind date her
first marriage
so there is a lot of different layers to
kamala harris
that ultimately they hope will attract
the vote
ravi you made it what does the harris
nomination mean for the
for the democratic party good to see you
that's right good to see you too you
know
a few technical glitches at the dnc last
night too so it's all part of the
genre it's all good um
look this was really historic uh
obviously um
what and given that what was very
interesting to me last night
um was that harris really spent the time
in that speech to talk about
herself her biography where she come
from what she believes in her family so
on and so forth
um whereas you know normally vice
presidential nominees spend a lot of
time really hitting the other side and
kind of being the attack dog
and and president obama ended up kind of
playing that role so
i thought that was very interesting and
really good because this is someone
a lot of voters you know although she
was in the primary a lot of voters
hadn't heard from before
so i thought it was important that she
had that opportunity to
to provide that background reince you
know republicans have have painted
senator harris as
some too too progressive others say
she's not progressive
enough how do you think that republicans
will take her on
well look um i i would go back to 2016.
and what i saw last night and monday and
tuesday was pretty much the same
playbook if you go back and watch
hillary clinton's speech
in 2016 she said that trump created
a movement a moment of reckoning barack
obama said that trump was full of
hate and anger there was two themes at
the democratic convention in 2016
the qualifications of hillary clinton
and the fact that
trump uh they claimed was too divisive
and the american people heard all that
they heard about the tweets they heard
about
you know all the things that the
democrats didn't like about trump
and what did they do they voted for for
donald trump
they drained the swamp and crushed the
way that things used to be
and so what the dnc is trying to do is
sort of harken back
to the way that things used to be you
know let's go back to that
and they've got to make the case for joe
biden and i don't
think they're doing anything differently
in this convention that they've been
trying basically since
2016. really right were you watching the
convention last night it felt very
different yeah i would
yeah i i i know you were i know you
weren't being sick
i gotta do your show every night but
no i don't look i people people people
that watch these
live you we have to watch it you have to
watch it
conventions generally don't include a
lot of persuadable voters
what matters is how does the news play
the next day
how does the news feed into folks that
aren't sitting and watching conventions
you know virtually
um th those types of people
are they have their minds to set they
know what they're doing
they either love trump or they don't
love trump or they
don't know much about biden but they
know they don't like the president so
they're watching so
persuadable voters don't watch virtual
conventions
but you know robbie last night the
president president obama said something
that i thought was very interesting he
said most voters
may have already made up their minds but
he really issued a call he said the
democracy of this country is at stake it
was a code red
he called it it seemed a national
emergency cleanup on aisle three
where he he at times it felt like he was
imp he was pleading and imploring voters
democrats and republicans to pay
attention to this that the democracy is
at stake
we have never seen anything like that
before what was your take on that robbie
yeah well you know right reince was
talking about 2016
uh you know and and and reince knows
more about wisconsin than me but
donald trump got less votes in wisconsin
than mitt romney right
trump didn't win by getting more votes
trump
won by people either deciding not to
turn out or voting for third party
candidates and i think
part of what president obama was trying
to do
was send out that call that beacon to
everybody to say we can't sit back you
know it's getting harder to vote in some
places because of covid
because of efforts to suppress the vote
and he was saying you got to do
everything you can to get that vote in
so i think that was very important
to reince's point uh you know about who
watches this
he was talking to the base and we really
heard the president president obama in
particular talking
to young people and so i think that was
a very important piece of work here
i get particularly worried like 2016 we
hear all the time biden's doing well
biden's doing well in the polls uh this
can change and so i think it was very
important to put people on notice
we all got to do our part i thought too
president obama made a point of saying
that listen he was a better president
because of joe biden i thought he made
that case very well
i want to talk to you maria elena
salinas to give us a closing point
about your take on the the the
convention last night
and d what do you think this means for
women in power what message does it send
there were a lot of women on the air
actually there have been a lot of women
in the last three days
on the air and showing in the convention
and showing how strong women can be but
also
encouraging women to go out and vote we
know that there are the majority of the
of the population is is female and at
this point when you look at the polls
you see that the majority of women are
supporting
um joe biden and kamala harris
but another theme that we have heard
throughout the whole
convention is making sure that people go
out and vote
um they were just saying that president
obama was talking to those
that maybe are on the fence i think at
this point there are very few
people that are on the fence there's
less undecided voters
than in previous elections right now the
important thing for the democrats is to
make sure
that people do not stay home and that's
why they have been pushing and pushing
and pushing
people to get out and vote women
minorities anyone who's out there
go vote well joe biden will joe biden
will make his case tonight and then the
republicans take the stage on monday and
both parties are saying
whatever you're thinking please go and
vote thank you very much
maria elena salinas good to see you
robbie mook very glad you made it
reince priebus always good to see you
too thank you for getting up
with us this morning because i know
you're up late